it's hard sometimes to look in the
mirror and really have to realize maybe
you're not the person that you
necessarily thought that you were that's
just a result of trauma and in life
circumstances have been so just very
public about my faith journey and how my
relationship with Jesus has helped me to
not be so hard on myself it's
discouraging out here sometimes you know
life smacks you in the face and it can
be hard to get back up God knows what
we're going through and just wants us to
be the best versions of ourselves and uh
so that for me in that perspective has
really changed everything
I think relationships for anybody are
they're hard to navigate you know it's a
constant
um you know dance if you will and uh
yeah I think being inspired by my
relationship has you know definitely
produced some some great music and you
know sometimes you get out that writer's
block or whatever but
um you know I I said it before but love
is kind of like the foundation of life
and love being the foundation of like
kind of like music in general so like
it's important to me that like I'm
singing about kind of what I'm living
basically for a while there I feel like
I kind of lost my purpose or felt like I
lost my purpose and um
and I feel like I finally got my purpose
back and I just want people to
be encouraged by that and be inspired by
that and know that hey maybe I lost my
purpose or maybe I'm don't know what my
purpose is but that just that word is so
important in life just to have something
to reach for and have that purpose and I
don't know I have this platform to do so
much and I want to be able to yeah our
people what is your purpose I think my
purpose is uh
to inspire people and use my use my
platform to help people because people
want people to win when
they're making an effort themselves to
one oh and of course before I wasn't
making the effort to want to win I was
just like Iceland isolating myself and
making myself feel our seem like I was
unrelatable
people love vulnerability yeah because
showing that you're human and showing
that you're like you make mistakes and
you are human and you
just relatable their strength and
vulnerability though right yeah there's
strength in you coming out and
explaining how vulnerable you are yeah
for sure
and it takes a lot as a Man Too to be
able to suck that Pride up and not
and because for a while I just like you
don't want to say sorry you don't want
to feel like you're weak you know
because a lot of times when you show
like your emotions you just feel weak or
people tell you that that's weak when
you cry or when you do this I'm like I'm
a really emotional guy
so
I'm like I'm a crier I'm someone who's
like really
open with my emotions yeah and for a
while I felt like I couldn't be and I
felt so guarded that I wasn't being able
to be my true self
a lot of celebrities and a lot of people
lose their ability to communicate with
normal people and it's because
they get to a point where they don't
have to engage and respect someone
else's thoughts and respect because it's
all about them and people around them
and laughing at jokes that aren't funny
it's yes yes yes yes yes yes and I had
those people around so I know and I
thought oh I must be the funniest dude
ever because everyone's always laughing
at everything I'm saying but um it got
to a point where I was just like
I could feel it I could feel like I
don't feel happy all these people are
smiling around me and making me feel
like I'm but it's unauthentic that's not
what God is like if God is based on love
it's I love you first regardless of what
you do
rather than
you do this and then I'll love you does
that make sense he loves you no matter
what yes yeah it doesn't mean you can go
do what you want but it's like you've
developed a relationship with God so
that you don't want to do that other
stuff yes you don't want to be
judgmental you don't want to hurt people
because you're like oh like God loves me
but when it's about religion and about
the works and about all this other stuff
that's just kind of irrelevant as soon
as I could understand my worth and knew
that like hey people aren't giving me
what I need like yeah people are always
wanting something I can never tell if
something's really authentic but when I
really sit in my room and I'm alone and
I can just like God are you there like I
feel this connection with something
that's a higher being it just and
picture it as being a perfect thing yeah
it just puts an ease to my soul that's
like can't describe I think you know
sometimes
as challenges come at us in all shapes
and sizes
um you know sometimes it's reflecting on
the blessings in our life that get us
through those chapters and so yeah
sometimes it's like you know if someone
who I'm going you know is going through
some stuff and I'm dealing with whatever
issues I'm dealing with on the
day-to-day like thinking back to you
know wow like I prayed for a wife I
wanted you know that consistent
consistency in my life and here I have
this beautiful blessing in my life that
often can just be overlooked because
we're just you know living together day
by day and you know challenges come up
and insecurities come up and you start
to kind of take for granted the person
that is with you but if you can remember
like hey I I pray for this moment I pray
for this person and here they are I
think just becoming an adult and
realizing what is really important in
this life and you know if I'm going to
continue to do this thing that I'm doing
releasing music and and facing the
scrutiny that comes with it you know
what is my what is my reason what is my
why why am I continuously putting myself
on the line to be criticized and you
know there has to be an ultimate goal
that far exceeds the the painful reality
of of people's opinions so
um I think for me that is identifying my
why here I have this opportunity to go
to the studio and make something with
this gift that I've been given you know
I don't have the gift of you know I I
didn't really I don't have much of an
education so it's like but I do have one
gift and that's to make music and so
like if I can use that to bring people
some sort of rest and reprieve and
um you know escape from their day-to-day
struggle like that's ultimately what I
wanted do and I think a lot of artists
they they have their own whatever their
reason or their meaning is behind their
stuff but for me I I want I want to just
be in the people business and I want to
keep connecting with culture and as long
as people want to hear from me then I
want to continue to give them uh records
and content whatever that looks like and
so like I want to keep evolving with the
times and I want to keep being uh
connected to what people are into and
um and I just want to continue to grow
as an artist and
give people what they want but also
um make sure that it is connected and
makes sense to what I'm I'm going
through and that kind of whole thing